hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll long time listeners readers etc
will know that i'm not someone who
thinks that consciousness
is a separate ontological category out
there in the world you know we've talked
about consciousness on the podcast a
number of times david chalmers philip
gough and other people
and a lot of people including those two
chalmers and goff think that we can't
just explain consciousness as the motion
of material stuff in the universe right
pure physicalism we need to have
separate categories for
mental actions and properties and so
forth it's a little bit vague in my mind
what other people want i don't want that
okay so people like me go around saying
consciousness is emergent from an
underlying purely physical structure and
we can go into what that means it's not
that we know how it emerges okay and i'm
not i'm not claiming that but we know
enough about the underlying behavior of
the physical stuff that it's very very
difficult to imagine adding in new stuff
that would somehow be responsible for
consciousness and so the word emergent
in that set of claims plays an important
role and the people who are skeptical of
people like me will often say like what
do you mean by emergence like you're
just that's just as magical and wish
hoping as our idea that there's a
separate ontological category and that's
completely fair right i mean
we do understand a lot about the
underlying stuff the electrons and
protons and neutrons and the different
forces that push them around that stuff
we understand very very well to say that
at some higher level of description
complicated things turn into
consciousness without adding any new
ingredients is a big leap and we would
like to understand that better so
forget about consciousness it's really
important to understand what you mean by
emergence what is it when does it happen
under what physical circumstances does a
complicated system exhibit emergent
behavior so today's guest is anil seth
who is a leading researcher on
consciousness and in fact nil has a new
book coming out that i can recommend to
you called being you
a new science of consciousness where he
pushes this line that consciousness is
an emergent phenomenon out of the
physical stuff it's always good when
people who you want to have on the
podcast have a new book coming out then
they are very much more likely to say
yes when you invite them on the podcast
but even better than that anil is
someone who thinks very carefully about
this idea of emergence he's not just
saying yeah yeah don't worry it'll
emerge he's thinking both about
consciousness and about emergence for
its own sake and in fact coincidentally
he and his collaborator lionel barnett
just came out with a paper
called dynamical independence
discovering emergent macroscopic
processes in complex dynamical systems
so again forget about consciousness for
the moment
just think about complex systems and ask
yourself under what circumstances do you
get emergent behavior
somehow we know a lot that we want to
have happening when emergence happens we
want to be able to describe systems
pretty well
on the basis of very very very
incomplete information we don't know all
the positions and velocities of all the
different atoms that make up you or me
or a cup of coffee or anything like that
and
the descriptions that we get of that
behavior at the macroscopic level the
emergent descriptions can look and feel
very very different than the underlying
descriptions i personally think this is
one of the biggest barriers to people
getting what it means to say you have an
emergent description because we tend to
think that we're laplace's demon that
you know sure i don't know where all the
atoms are but i know where a lot of them
are that's almost as good right but we
don't have nowhere close to the
information you would need to be
laplace's demon and so what we need to
do is understand the relationship
between the underlying theory and the
emergent theories and anil and lionel
barnett just wrote a paper about exactly
that so because he wants to promote his
new book on consciousness and i wanted
to talk about emergence i invited him on
the podcast and mostly i'll admit we
talk about emergence because that's what
i wanted to talk about so this is really
the first uh full podcast episode
episode mostly devoted to the topic of
emergence and what it is but we do get
into uh consciousness because there are
similarities between the general theory
of emergence and the general theory of
consciousness for its own sake you know
the conscious brain
looks at the world and gets a very tiny
slice of the pie right it doesn't see
all of what's going on in the outside
world but nevertheless
it constructs a story about it that's an
amazing thing maybe there's some
relationship there between what the
brain's doing and how we talk about
emergence more generally i don't know
i'm crossing my fingers maybe it's true
this is all very cutting edge stuff
again plenty of work here to be done for
future generations of smart young people
growing up to be scientists and
philosophers and thinking hard about
this so let's go
[Music]
vanilla seth welcome to the mindscape
podcast thanks for having me sean
so you're uh one of the neuroscientists
out there who's willing to talk about
consciousness i mean there's many
neuroscientists to talk about
consciousness but you're even willing to
talk about the more philosophical side
of things and we know i've had people
like david chalmers and philip gough on
the podcast who think that there is uh
this hard problem right this
impossibility of explaining the first
person perspective of conscious
experiences if we're just physicalists
materialists who think that it's just a
collective behavior of atoms in the
brain so tell us just to set the stage
where you come down on these kinds of
questions how do you think about
consciousness vis-a-vis the physical
stuff of which we are made
i suppose i'm a pretty standard
physicalist or materialist
that i think my starting position anyway
is that
consciousness is part of the natural
order of things it's part of the natural
world
everything that we know closely ties it
to the brain at least in some way
at least the kind of consciousness that
i'm interested in explaining which is
the consciousness that we are familiar
with in our everyday life the difference
between
being awake and aware and having
experiences of drinking coffee or
watching tv
and falling into a dreamless sleep or
going under general anesthesia
these are differences in in
consciousness that apply
to human beings and probably to many
other living organisms as well
and they do seem to be closely coupled
with something about the brain the
question is is what so now that's
that's
a fairly typical empirical
physicalist standpoint i am
in the end a little agnostic about how
consciousness will turn out to be part
of our overall story of the universe
yeah
the idea of the hard problem which you
mentioned david chalmers extremely
influential and very articulate in
putting this
this apparent mystery the idea that we
could explain everything about how the
brain works in physical terms
how neurons interact with each other how
they explain all the capabilities and
functions
of things that brains do and these
functions can be things
in the vicinity of consciousness how
perception works how we pay attention
but for chalmers there's always going to
be something left over why should any of
this physical processing
uh be associated with or identical to
the redness of red or the sharpness of a
toothache
why is there anything uh going on for
the system in terms of subjective
experience that's the hard problem how
does how does consciousness fit into our
physical picture of the universe
as a whole and that's where you get
these kind of menu of metaphysical
options yeah
um you have dualism that they're two
completely separate modes of existence
then there's the awkward problem of how
they interact
uh you have pan psychism which sort of i
think is an easy get out to the whole
mystery just says well you know if we
can't figure it out then we'll just say
we just build it in from the from the
ground up and say it's here there and
to some extent everywhere or
just as
bad in my view idealism that say well
consciousness is kind of all there is
and the problem is
not how you get mind from matter but how
you get matter from mind so i'm actually
i don't know the ultimate resolution of
that
i i also think that conscious
experiences exist as there's another
camp which is the sort of strong
illusionist cam
which says something like
we're mistaken about there being a
mystery at all
when we think conscious experiences are
something special that are hard to fit
into the picture of the
universe well that's just because we're
misunderstanding in some crucial way
what the explanatory target is but i
just prefer to start almost like a
practical matter that
conscious experiences exist in fact i
think that's probably the only thing
that i'm really sure of is that
i am having conscious experiences
um i'm also pretty sure that there's an
objective physical reality out there
consisting of something and some of the
other politicians will know much more
about
what that is the problem is how do we
how do we relate the two and in in
trying to relate the two
maybe
this apparent mystery of the hard
problem
will evaporate will dissolve in a
similar though not identical way to
how
the apparent mystery of life eventually
evaporated when people got on with the
job of explaining
how living systems work so i call it a
bit of tongue-in-cheek the real problem
of consciousness is to explain why
conscious experiences are the way they
are
in terms of things happening in brains
and bodies and by pursuing that agenda
hopefully they're not guaranteed but
hopefully the big metaphysical house and
wise will become less mysterious so i'm
i don't know anything about
consciousness at a detailed level myself
other than being uh an avid user of it
but uh i do know something about physics
in the physical world so i have gone on
record and even written a paper you know
trying to explain how
whatever consciousness is whatever is
going to be the ultimate explanation for
it don't make your first move to change
the laws of physics to account for it uh
which fine i mean that's that's a whole
school of thought but then so what does
account for it and
the word i like to use is emergence
right how there's different levels of
description and there's a higher level
where we talk about people and
consciousness and so forth so i had
david chalmers on the podcast and you
know i i use that word emergence because
i i do
uh and i actually brought it up here
because i want to quote david exactly i
don't want to misrepresent him he said
yeah my view is that emergence is
sometimes used as a kind of a magic word
to make us feel good about things we
don't understand
how do you get this from this oh it's
emergent but what do you really mean
so now to be fair to david he's thought
a lot about emergence and written about
it but uh clearly he's a little bit
skeptic it's going to do enough of the
work
are you on the in the camp that says
that we should be able to ultimately
someday think about consciousness as an
emergent phenomenon
i think emergence used properly and
carefully so i'm with david on this that
it's not to be used as some sort of
elixir or magic magic sauce special
sauce that
that just relabels the mystery um
you don't just solve consciousness by
replacing with another mystery
but there is something intuitive about
many systems complex systems that admit
of multiple levels of description
and
the brain is a highly complex system as
as we as we know composed of
86 billion neurons and a thousand times
more connections between them something
like that very very complicated
yet it gives rise to
relatively
easily characterizable macroscopic
properties large-scale properties
whether that's a behavior of a whole
organism or a a mental state or a single
perception i'm having a unified
perceptual experience of what's going on
around me
right now
there are things that apply to the to
the collective rather than the
individual yeah so how do we
characterize um
that relationship
i think
it's almost trivially true to say that
consciousness emerges from neural
activity uh it's the the devil is in the
detail what do we mean by that how does
that actually help shed explanatory
light
on the relationship between the level of
description
at some lower level whether it's neurons
or some other level and the level of
description of what's going on for me as
a conscious subject
is it worth uh
trying to go into the difference between
weak and the strong emergence is that a
difference that you care about
yeah i think definitely and i i think um
from what i've read when you've written
about emergence i think you care about
it as well
which is which is good i think we all
should because
it's in these distinctions that
transitions from being just another
mystery to i think something we can get
both a theoretical and uh
quantitative grasp on so this idea at
least as i understand it and i wonder if
you understand it the same way that
strong emergence is the more mysterious
idea of emergence where you might have
some macroscopic property that is in
principle
not explicable by or reducible to
the microscopic components that make it
up and furthermore
that it may exert some sort of downward
causal power on these micro level
constituents affect them in in some way
yeah that goes beyond the causal
interactions unfolding among the micro
level components
themselves
this is
weird you know this is a kind of
it's uncomfortably close to magic to
talk about emergence this way it's
unclear how it fits into a physicalist
picture of the universe though some
philosophers will claim that that it can
do that there's no
real problem with bringing
new things in at higher levels like this
um but for me it's it's a little
of a dramatic move
i don't quite know what to what to make
of it how it would actually
work and i think most tellingly
there aren't very many good examples
where you would be tempted to to think
that this is happening and very
revealingly one of the only examples
that reliably comes up is consciousness
yes that's right so it's just this is
this is this whole reciprocal mystery
thing
now weak emergence is
very different it preserves the
intuition
that the whole is more than the sum of
the parts in some sort of interesting
way
so good there are many examples there
are things like gliders in john conway's
game of life the example i like to use
is
flocking birds which
really nice computer simulations of
burst blocking but i see them most
evenings here in brighton over the ruins
of one of our old peers you have these
flocks of starlings
that
murmurations of starlings i think
they're properly called
that flock together before roosting for
the evening and the flock really does
seem to have
a life of its own
and it seems very appealing that the
behavior of individual birds within the
flock is somehow guided by the flock as
an entity
that's sort of flying around remaining
part of the flock in some way
um
and
but there's nothing mysterious going on
here there are just birds following
local rules how they fly together as far
as we know certainly you can simulate
things purely locally the birds are
behaving local rules and if you set it
up the right way you get what looks to
an external observer
like a
an emerging property something that's
more than the sum of its parts
and so the question is how do you
operationalize that how do you become a
bit more specific about what we can what
systems display weak emergence and what
don't
and here i've been most influenced by
the
philosopher mark badal
who um
describes weak emergence as something
for which
uh
there is an explanation a macroscopic
property for which there is an
explanation in in terms of microscopic
components
but it's what he calls incompressible
you can only figure out what the
global property is by simulating
exhaustively the microscopic
interactions
um
and that's i think quite a nice
starting point but it's a kind of all or
none starting point so i think that
nowadays and this is something i've been
interested in for well more than a
decade now is
how do we get a little bit more
um
empirical quantitative graded about
these things given a system
can we measure the extent to which
uh
a macroscopic property like a flock or
some other property maybe at some
global activity pattern in neurons can
we measure the extent to which that is
weakly emergent from its constituent
parts
your home isn't just a roof over your
head it's a reflection of who you are
and joy bird helps you create a space
that shows off your personality and
inspires you to live your best life joy
bird offers modern customizable
furniture for every space available in a
variety of vibrant durable fabric
options and now joybird's semi-annual
sale is here ordering furniture online
has never been easier or more fun you
can choose from over 18 000
customization options or browse curated
collections to find the perfect piece
for your one-of-a-kind style and joybird
is committed to creating quality
furniture and a more sustainable future
each piece is made with incredible care
using responsibly sourced materials free
of harmful chemicals quality
craftsmanship stain and scratch
resistant fabrics and a limited lifetime
warranty joybird furniture can handle
anything your family throws at it
literally finally joybird stands by its
quality and craftsmanship so they offer
90 day returns if it's not everything
you hoped for just send it back so
create a space that brings you joy with
joybird visit joybird.com mindscape and
get 30 off your purchase that's 30
percent off at joybird.com
mindscape
so
yeah you've sparked a lot of ideas in my
brain i know that you're the guest on
the podcast but let me just say a couple
things that that come to mind when you
say that and you can choose to respond
to them or not um
first i think that it's a terrible
choice of vocabulary that we're stuck
with to talk about weak and strong
emergents because they're almost
opposites of each other right they're
not two different versions of the same
thing the whole idea of weak immersions
is that everything in here's in the
microscopic components ultimately
and emerge in that sense means you look
at the collective behavior of it
whereas strong emergence means that when
you have this collection something new
appears and the emergence has a totally
different kind of meaning it emerges out
of something that is not just the
microscopic dynamics by itself so
being that as it may maybe that is what
is contributing a little bit to the
confusion having said that i i have
thought about it hard and i do think
that it is not
insensible to imagine something like
strong emergence
the example i would give is you know an
atom or a an electron an elementary
particle obeys the laws of physics and
those laws of physics are really really
local right they say the electron cares
about what is going on in other quantum
fields at the point where the electron
is nowhere else but what if the real
laws of physics say that that's pretty
good when you have two or three or ten
electrons but when you have 10 to the 23
it's not good anymore there are
literally new laws that come in and
there's some feature of the organization
that the electron is stuck in that needs
to be taken into consideration i think
that would count as strong emergence and
it would also
be completely incompatible with
everything we know about physics so it's
you're welcome to think about it uh but
it is something very different whereas
just to finish up
maybe the idea of strong emergence does
make sense when both your your sort of
finely grained theory and your coarsely
grained macroscopic theory
are themselves theories of complex
structures so like with the starlings or
the birds flocking
a bird is not an electron that's all
right so a bird uh has its own internal
structure and its memory and things like
that and so maybe when you relate those
two levels to each other there is some
sense in which strong emergence is a
useful concept to lean on but when
you're relating the brain to the atoms
of which it's made i don't see how it
can personally make sense
let me respond to both of those i think
there's i i kind of agree mostly i
although i quite like the the weak
strong
terminology because for me it echoes
other domains in which
that terminology has been used and it's
often the case that people
are initially
attracted to the strong version of
whatever phenomenon it is whether it's
something like strong artificial
intelligence which is supposed to
connect genuine intelligence rather than
the simulation of it or strong
artificial life similar idea
there's something about the strong x in
which the x
possesses some quiddity some essence
of the phenomenon that you're talking
about
but it almost always turns out that in
fact you make more progress by taking a
weak stance and thinking okay how do we
how do we under how do we stimulate how
do we understand the mechanisms that
exhibit some of the properties that we
associate with this phenomenon but
without trying to sort of build it in as
a fundamental essence
um there's an old paper i was very
influenced by
i think came out of was one of the
original papers in network theory uh
back from mark granovetto called the
strength of weak ties again just having
this idea that weak weak things weak
interactions weakly coupled systems can
can give you really powerful effects and
for some reason i quite like that that
way of thinking that not trying to do so
much um can actually lead to making more
progress we see the same thing in
consciousness too actually this gets
back to just where we started that if
you try to
solve the hard problem head on and
explain why consciousness is part of the
universe maybe you want to build a
system that is artificially conscious
going after strong artificial
consciousness
it's unclear you're going to make much
progress because we just don't know how
consciousness fits into the
the our understanding of the universe in
general but taking a weak approach and
just saying okay look consciousness has
these properties and let's try to
understand them individually one by one
you get somewhere so i do i do quite
like that
as to the the other point about whether
there are legitimate situations in which
to invoke something like strong
emergence
i think i i don't to be honest i don't
know
enough about the re the relevant domains
of physics to know
whether that is justifiable because
there's also another form of emergence
which often gets overlooked which is
nominal emergence um
which is built again even though the
emergence where you you just have a
property that can apply to a a hole that
just by definition cannot apply to the
parts
so the example i think that mark badal
uses is a circle is nominally emergent
from the set of points that make it up
there's nothing
mysterious going on here it's just that
that a circle is not the kind of
property that can ever be attributed to
a point a single point it's it's only
something
that a collection of things can have
so my
intuition is that if you combine that
with a sufficiently
rich version of weak emergence
then you then you get everything you
need and the key thing for me about this
weak emergence picture is that
is the is the causal closure of the
physical world yeah you want things to
run through all the way down it of
course it there are concepts that we
will use to describe things at higher
level of descriptions ontologies that
appear
at more abstract levels of organization
which can be absolutely essential
for our understanding
of a system and they are real too dan
daniel dennett talks about real patterns
the fact that something
is described at a higher level doesn't
mean that it it doesn't exist it just
means that that's a that's a higher
level description
can be very very useful for our can be
essential for our understanding of how a
system works um but it doesn't mean
there's some
disruption to the to the sort of
picture of physical causality that
ultimately runs right down to whatever
reality really is which again is is in
your wheelhouse not mine fortunately but
we did i'll also plug the appearance of
dan dennett on the podcast where we
center the whole conversation on this
idea of real patterns and how
large-scale things can have an identity
of their own even if they're just
depending on the small-scale things and
as you imply there are those who take
the opposite tack right that you need to
sort of add more ontological categories
at each level and consciousness is going
to be something that only exists at this
at this higher level but
the challenge that those people would
give to you and me
is you know
again d de-magicify
this word that you're using of emergence
and so if you think that there that
consciousness or experience or whatever
is not a separate category if it just
comes out of the motion of atoms and and
neurons etc at some level how exactly
does that happen so i was thrilled to
see that you've actually written a paper
about at least beginning maybe we can
say to understand how exactly that
happens when
you can talk about a complex system with
many moving parts in terms of a higher
level
emergent description so maybe why don't
you tell us the you know the punch line
to that paper
i'll be happy to um
it is as you say it's a very much a
starting point and
there's actually a few different
approaches now and i think this is for
me a promising sign because i don't know
which approach is going to be right and
having
a diversity of different ideas out there
is a healthy situation uh to be in and
the paper i think you're referring to is
a very recent one with my colleague
lionel barnett who's a proper
mathematician in our collaboration uh
and he sort of takes vague ideas and and
makes beautiful uh beautiful concepts
from them
but it actually began for me about 10
years ago it's
the first
way i thought about how to
operationalize this idea of emergence
and was
really taking mark vidal's idea about
weak emergence and thinking
how can we build
some simple measures
that make that work in practice and so
you unpack it one stage further his
initial
proposition was that a weekly emergent
property
is
you you have to
run the microscopic level exhaustively
to extract the macroscopic property
you have to simulate it entirely there's
no shortcut
conceptually
he described a weakly emergent property
let's let's think about the flock of
birds again just to give it some just to
guide our intuitions we have a flock of
birds wheeling around the pier here uh
to call it weekly immersion is to say
that the flock is
simultaneously both dependent on
the birds that make it up it's not that
you have a flock floating somewhere
where the birds aren't
the the flock is made of the birds i
think philosophically we would call it
super benion on the birds um but the
flock seems to have an autonomy
it has this is the life of its own thing
the behavior of the flock seems to be
more than the sum of the behavior of the
individual birds
in some interesting way that leads us to
say oh it's a flock and it's not just
birds flying randomly all over the place
or birds flying in some sort of super
fighter jet formation where they're
they're very rigid
and there's no there's no interesting
dynamics going on
so my challenge then was well how do we
how do we measure that let's say we have
a simulated bird flock
what
what's a way of applying a measure so
that we get a high number when it looks
like a flock and a low number when it
looks like the birds are just randomly
doing their thing
or flying in a rigid formation
and the approach then that i took was to
use a method
that i've been using in neuroscience for
a bit called granger causality
and this is
speaking of terrible names this is
another terrible name because gradual
causality has nothing to do with
causality it's to do with prediction
and
to unpack it very simply
uh it basically provides a way of
measuring information flow between two
variables let's say you have two
variables that change over time
we're used to thinking whether they're
correlated or not do they do they share
information um
and correlation is a
bi-directional notion
if a is correlated with b then b is
correlated with a to the same extent
it's it's symmetric and in information
theory as you know mutual information
would be the equivalent um
they share information but imagine if
you could put an arrow on it and say
that
a is conveying information to be but b
is not conveying information to a or is
conveying less information
and there are ways to
to measure that
statistically and
what clyde granger who developed this
concept of grainger causality did was
was basically say
you can say that a
granger causes b
and i have to get this right because
always always messes me up when i'm
trying to explain it you say that a
granger causes b
if
a contains
information that helps you predict the
future of b
that's not already in the past of b
so you have a time asymmetry going on
here now because causality is often
about time is in is just intrinsically
caught up with our notions of causality
so basically a is giving you information
that helps you predict how b unfolds
that's not already in in b
um and now you can see that this is
not necessarily symmetric so information
is flowing from a to b in that sense
exactly so it's a way of actually
measuring given two
time series that fluctuate over time
this could be any the trajectories of
birds in a flock or
the trajectories of prices in the stock
market or the electrical voltages of
neurons in the brain they could be
anything
described in the form of
variables that change over time time
series
you can ask the question um
does one granger cause the other
which is equivalent does one transfer
information to the other the equivalent
of grainger causality and information
theory is called transfer entropy that's
and it's it's that idea that it's now a
not a shared information but a is
giving information to be because it's
helping predict its future when you say
the equivalent are they mathematically
the same or these two labels that means
slightly different things in different
contexts transfer entropy and grainger
causality
i'm very glad you asked that question
because it's one of those beautiful
examples where conceptually they're very
very similar
so but they came out of different
mathematical contexts so granger
causality came out of this
this statistical uh framework of
ultra-regressive modelling which is just
it's a way of saying you model variables
based on
weighted sums of their past it's just
one particular statistical framework
transfer entropy same concept but the
mathematical infrastructure for it is
information theory
and um
i always thought that they were very
closely related and that somebody would
have shown that they were
identical under certain conditions but
my um
my colleagues at sussex this was now 11
years 12 years ago so lionel barnett and
my other
postdoc at the time adam barrett
basically
realized that nobody had shown that and
showed it and it was one of those great
very quick papers that that that we did
um
to give they did it really and
we showed that if variables are gaussian
which is to say if they're described by
normal distributions bell curve
distributions an assumption you might
often make
then in fact grainger causality and
transfer entropy are exactly equivalent
well one is one half the other
which is really nice because it actually
it's not just it's not a trivial thing
because you you connect now two
different domains of mathematics in a
way you connect this whole framework of
regret autoregressive modeling which is
very convenient to work with it's very
easy to build models of data that way
but you know you now can translate it
directly into information theory
and
talk about bits per second of
information flow and having a measure of
information flow in terms of
in terms of bits that you don't get the
other way so there is a there is a very
deep relationship between the two
concepts
if you've ever wanted to learn a new
subject or even just refresh your memory
about a subject you used to be familiar
with you can do that at onerium that's
w-o-n-d-r-i-u-m
wonderium is a streaming service that
used to be the great courses plus that
has incredible content with answers to
millions of the wise how's where's
what's whose and whens you've ever had
for example i used to be on the chess
club back in high school but it's been
decades since i've seriously played and
wondering has a great course on how to
play chess taught by jeremy silman an
international master and winner of the
us open all of one dream's videos are
academically comprehensive relentlessly
entertaining and led by engaging experts
i know you'll love one dream too so
we've arranged a special limited time
offer for listeners a free month of
unlimited access to get this offer sign
up now through the special url
onerium.com
mindscape that's
d r w-o-n-d-r
um dot com slash mindscape there's so
much you can learn in a month go to
onerium.com mindscape to start your free
trial
so in so let's just uh give us ourselves
a an independent definition of transfer
entropy is it something like how many
bits of information are flowing from one
series of events to this other series
sort of i think that yes i mean that's
that would be the way of describing
interpreting what the transfer entropy
metric means
to say what transfer entropy is
in information theory terms if i can get
this right it's again you've got your
two variables and it's it's to say that
the
it's the degree to which um
the
future of let's say b
is
is conditionally dependent on the past
of another variable
a
conditioned on its own past
um so there's always this thing about
what what other what what what is
another variable bringing to the table
in terms of
predictive ability or additional
information
so you have b all by itself and you can
say well from what b is doing like if b
is a
uh a football flying through the air
obeying newton's laws you know and you
can predict what it's going to do next
uh but then there's some other variable
that maybe if you knew that also
would or would not teach you even more
than from what you knew about the past
of the football
yes although you just raised one of the
important constraints in practice where
these things make sense which is that
they only really can be used in
stochastic systems there has to be some
okay some at least apparent randomness
to what's going on if it's deterministic
you don't get
any
you already know what's going to happen
so there's no way to compare how much
more you know by introducing another
variable
so these things have certain domains of
application at least in the way
we would use them they have to be
applied to stochastic systems that are
stationary and so on and so on i mean
would it count to have a apparent
stochasticity because the fundamental
laws are perfectly deterministic but we
don't know exactly the initial
conditions like we have in statistical
mechanics
yes
yes so long as it's as long as it's of
stochastic with respect to the tools
you're using to model the system
then then it's okay
okay then then these things work fine so
your example is yeah it makes sense you
can watch basically you watch one thing
going on in the world you can imagine
let's go back to a neuron a neuron is
firing
and
you can try to figure out what will
you could try to predict on the basis of
the past of that neuron firing what its
future firing is going to be like
and then you can just ask the question
okay i can do this maybe i'm 70
good at predicting the future firing of
this neuron
now i look at another
neuron
can i do better by
by bringing in knowledge from this what
this other neuron is doing and if i can
in some in this statistical way then yes
there's information flow between the two
there's grainger causality between the
two
but we've gone we've gone quite far from
emergency
let's bring it back but the the next
step is is actually pretty simple which
is instead of thinking of
two
um
two neurons or two birds flying around
or two stock prices we think of two
levels of description so you've got your
macroscopic level of description and
your microscopic level of description
you've got your flock of birds and
you've got your
individual birds that make it up and now
you can apply some of these same
concepts to characterizing the relation
between the flock
and
the birds between the macroscopic and
the microscopic and now there are many
options for how you might use these
concepts to
come up with a range of different
measures of emergence like things
so for instance you could say
um
and this was my original approach 10
years ago i could say okay does
the flock as a whole
predict its own future behavior
better than i can do
from just the birds alone
is there sort of some self causality
self-information for the flock
conditioned on the parts that make it up
uh and if so then you could then i could
say well that's a way of of
operationalizing this idea that the
flock has a life of its own it's driving
its own behavior in a way
um that goes beyond what i can say by
looking at the parts now this isn't to
say there's something spooky going on
because to make that claim i have to
have imperfect knowledge of the system
it's it's only just the way it's in
given imperfect knowledge of the system
some things will look like they're
flocking other things won't yeah and can
i distinguish these cases and it turns
out yes i can by using this this method
um so that's one approach
in another approach and this is what
with lionel barnett we were working on
recently it's a slightly different thing
imagine that you don't
know that there's a flaw this is another
question that comes up in emergence like
we often ground it with these
discussions of what's intuitive like a
bunch of birds that flock is intuitive
we know we can see there's something
going on there that's interesting
uh gliders in the game of life it's they
leap out at you which is why they're
interesting
but maybe emergent properties don't
always leap out to us as as observers of
them if i look at a whole bunch of
neurons flickering under some calcium
imaging thing
maybe they're all synchronizing together
that's pretty obvious
but if they're not if they're just
flashing on and off
it's very hard for me as an external
observer to know whether there's
anything interestingly weakly emergent
in their global patterns
and that's the problem of identification
of an emergent property so what with
lionel we were interested in was can we
develop
methods
that allow us to in a data-driven way
identify candidates
weekly emergence
macroscopic properties another word for
that would be course grainings
higher level abstractions of the system
that have this kind of property and we
did it in a slightly different way so
for lionel the key idea was that
a
a candidate
weakly emergent variable must be what
we call dynamically independent from its
microscopic underpinnings
which just
again this just means that knowing
what's going on at the microscopic level
does not help you predict what's going
on at the macroscopic level
so that's why we use that word dynamical
independence
doesn't necessarily mean in this case
that you that the
macroscopic
level has to predict itself in any
interesting way it just however
much you can do that it just has to be
independent of what's going on in the
bottom which is why i say there's this
whole variety of different options now
how to think about
what an emergent property might be and
what we're doing in my group at the
moment is trying to
flesh out many of these different
directions and figure out how they how
they relate there's not going to be one
single answer
well i think i don't want to let this go
by too quickly because that what you
just said is is not only very beautiful
but
philosophically really really important
i think but when i have these arguments
with people who
uh would like to let a richer ontology
into their universe so they wanna like
like we said before
have new fundamental concepts at every
level and
in practice you know uh if i say it's
not exactly applicable to your uh
definition but if i say a chair or a
table is emerging from a bunch of atoms
well i'm helping myself to the fact that
i see tables and chairs and i know what
they are already long before i ever knew
what atoms were and i think that a lot
of the people who want these richer
ontologies are saying like there's no
way you'll ever find tables and chairs
if you just start with atoms and so your
response to gussied up a little bit is
yes i can and here's how to do it here
are the equations that say here are the
conditions under which we find these
emergent structures
yeah that's right i mean that would
that's that's the intuition that's the
that's the motivation anyway that's i
don't know how far you get that way but
i think i always want to push back
against
the temptation as you say to just bring
in new things because it seems like you
can't get there without doing that i
mean this is the whole
it's the same sort of intuition that i
think drives a hard problem this idea
that you'll never get to consciousness
just by thinking about what neurons do
but there's a whole there's a lot of
things neurons can do
that we've not yet learned to think
about
and uh
we just need to we need to exhaust the
possibilities of thinking about what
very complicated systems of billions of
neurons can in fact do
before reaching the conclusion that
consciousness is not among them now this
might seem philosophically naive because
you might be able to look however
complicated it is it still will not get
there
but i i'm just inclined to bracket that
and say i might be being philosophically
naive here i still think we've not
exhausted the possibilities of the kinds
of things
that physical systems can do given a
sufficiently rich
uh interpretation of them and let's just
see how far we get and be guided by
uh
by the ultimate target whether it's
consciousness or emergence or try i mean
here's the thing i see
emergence in this sense as
a way to enrich our descriptions of
physical systems that might have
relevance to consciousness i'm not
saying that we will demonstrate that
consciousness is an emergent property or
come up with some equivalence
but
it allows us to characterize the
behavior of complex systems in ways
that might help us
get closer to the explanatory target of
consciousness like there is a sense in
which conscious experiences
are unified and global and seem to be
more than the sum of
the things that make them up so it might
be very useful to have some something in
our toolbox that allows us to assess
these claims in general and then see how
they
stand up when we apply them to let's say
the brain dynamics when people
lose consciousness under anesthesia or
fall asleep or other such other such
states do weekly emergent properties
dissolve in those cases or not it's an
empirical question
and if you think that you can answer
this question uh using equations that's
always the best part right there are
equations here this is not just uh some
words we're throwing around um so you
can say i have a complex system made of
many little pieces here are the
chunks i need to divide it up into to
get emergent behavior
the next hard question hard in the old
fashioned sense of hard not trauma of a
sense is
is this generic this kind of behavior is
this robust like when i have a whole
bunch of little things
uh
will it inevitably be the case that i
can chunk it up into some emergent big
things or
are there multiple different
incompatible ways of chunking it up into
big things or is the generic situation
that there's there's no way that
emergence is a special delicate flower
of some sort
yeah these are all great questions and i
i think you probably have better answers
than i do i don't know i think that
it's it's appealing to me when we think
about
this approach of discovery of candidate
weekly emergent properties one one other
appealing pro thing about that is we
don't have to make assumptions
or too many assumptions about that don't
have to assume there's a single
level at which emergence plays out
you can in fact look for
emergent properties at
multiple different levels of abstraction
what we would call multiple different
course grainings and in that sense
figure out an emergence portrait for a
system
do all systems have emergence portraits
well yes but some might might be trivial
some might be just like you know well
there's there's really nothing
interesting happening at any given scale
and i could construct
just for instance a system of totally
randomly interact random particles um
just moving around and not interacting
uh with each other at all
for me i would ex
i would i would be happy
or be reassured for any candidate
measure of emergence to come out
basically flat however you looked at
that at that system because that's not a
system where i want to see
uh expect to see emergency i then have
to struggle with what do i mean by
emergence if it can happen in a system
where nothing is interacting with
anything
and i i think
i'll make a guess i don't think i know
the answer to the question that i posed
myself but my guess is personally that
emergence is a rare kind of thing in the
space of all systems we can imagine
the existence of
these higher level descriptions that are
as good at predicting what will happen
next as you can be
without extra microscopic information is
probably
very unlikely if you just picked
randomly you know how to how to coarse
grain in some sense um and in fact i
think that yes i think sorry
it opens up maybe um
you know even more things to explore
like the nestedness
of these descriptions right so i mean
not only
do we imagine that atoms
uh emerge into a higher level
description in terms of cells in a
biological organisms and cells emerge
into a higher level of organisms and
organisms to societies or whatever but
probably
there is no
universe in which
something like atoms emerge into
something like cells
and something like organisms without it
being nested right like without the
organisms themselves emerging from the
cells in some way and these are all just
speculations conjectures let's call it a
conjecture that sounds more impressive
but that's the kind of question we can
now start investigating
yeah that sounds appropriate i do think
that the first thing you said though i
think is probably a
it's still probably a conjecture but i
think it's quite
easy at least in some systems to check
and validate so it's certainly the case
that for many sorts of systems you might
you might write down that
arbitrary course grainings will not have
this property of emergence will not have
this property of dynamical independence
so it will be
it will be rare for many example classes
of system um which suggests that it's
rare in in general but then you know the
real world is is not
the real world is complicated so quite
how rare these things are in the world
as it is
is much harder to make a strong
statement about
and the nestedness question is is very
interesting as well very hard to get get
a quantitative grasp on that you have to
do something that gets a little bit
recursive and gets complicated that's
why we have graduate students right that
you know the young people are energetic
enough to address address these
questions but
but okay so now we have some framework
on the ground uh you know i'll we'll
link to the paper if people want to look
it up there i'll i'll warn you ahead of
time listeners there are a lot of
equations in the paper but that's good
it's healthy for you um i was i was
surprised to learn there's a whole book
that uh lionel wrote about transfer
entropy that that people can try to
learn the basics about but
let's go back then to our initial
motivation for this which was
consciousness so have we learned
anything from this investigation about
the claim that consciousness is a kind
of emerging phenomenon
i would say not yet besides
besides just the conceptual
clarifications besides
deflating a little bit
this association that people intuitively
make between consciousness and strong
emergence
just by showing that there are other
ways to think about emergence
i think is a
contribution um
another way that contribution plays out
is that
you can also think about downward
causality or top-down causality in this
framework in a
in a metaphysically innocent way in
you don't have to think about
competing causes where you have like
actual top-down causes that compete with
causes at the micro level and then you
have all these problems of which which
cause dominates and so on
now i can simply say from the
perspective of an observer
are there occasions where the
macroscopic variable whatever it is
helps me predict the evolution of the
microscopic components better than
knowing what the microscopic components
are doing
and again this is not
in not introducing anything
that challenges a physicalist picture
where causes just run all the way down
but there might be systems where that's
the case and there might be systems
where that's not the case back to the
original
bird flocking thing it turns out that
certainly for the measure i was using 10
years ago that indeed when when you have
a bird flock
you do observe information flow from the
flock to the individual birds in a way
that you don't when they're all flying
randomly around
so just having these things in in your
toolkit
uh
helps us resist some of the otherwise
unfortunate tendencies to think of
consciousness as necessarily something
magic yeah
the work to be done is how much
purchase
empirically and how much explanatory
insight do these
concepts offer
in practice when when we flesh them out
and that's
something that
is is a story yet to be told and there's
a few
a few groups with one group doing this
there are some other groups doing this
people at the university of wisconsin
madison and julio tinoni's group have
other sorts of measures of emergence um
but there's a lot of there's a lot of
tricksiness in how you actually apply
these in practice and
what assumptions you have to make and
all the the usual stuff which which
doesn't make it
easy
uh but my hope would be that
if we could as a as a first step
show that
weekly emergent variables can be
identified in conscious states that are
not there in unconscious states they can
maybe use to predict uh
levels of consciousness in people um in
maybe with better accuracy and fidelity
than other other measures of global
brain dynamics i think that would be a
start i certainly don't think it's it's
it's suddenly going to be the solution
to all our questions about consciousness
not at all it's just another way of
building explanatory bridges that might
carry some of the weight of this
apparent mystery
what's the secret to your best night's
sleep first toss out the memory foam and
upgrade to awara awara features natural
and sustainable latex tapped from real
rubber trees humanely sourced new
zealand wool that promotes cooling and
airflow and breathable cotton for
enhanced moisture control and softness
awara is known for a weightless feeling
with neutral spine alignment so no
sinking or pulling on the natural curve
of your back
furthermore awara features a best in the
industry
365 night trial no questions asked if
you don't like it they'll take it back
that's with free shipping and returns
and a forever warranty so for a limited
time you get 499 dollars in free
accessories two natural latex pillows
cotton sheets and a waterproof mattress
protector with every mattress purchase
and feel good knowing that awara plants
10 trees with every purchase to redeem
go to
www.awarasleep.com that's awa
r-a-s-l-e-e-p dot com discount auto
apply to checkout
well one of the interesting things about
your proposal uh based on the transfer
entropy to define dynamical independence
and therefore emergence
is that it
talks
specifically about the internal the self
dynamics of the system from what the
system has done what will it do next uh
you could imagine a different approach
based on the fact that one of the
features of the flock of starlings is
that i see it
as a flock right i mean one one could
imagine basing a theory of emergence on
the fact that uh or or a theory of
coarse grainings and macroscopic states
based on the fact that i only have
observational
access to certain features right when i
see the cream and the coffee mixing
together i see the gross features of
where the cream is and where the coffee
is not the individual atoms and
therefore i talk about cream and coffee
is higher level emergent phenomena in
some sense so is there
i don't even know what my question here
is uh
is that way of thinking about emergence
in terms of observational capabilities
or access
the same as related to independent of uh
your sort of internal dynamics way of
thinking about it
i think it's related although
we are i think we're both
speculating about this now i think it
might be related in the sense that
um if we have a
a data-driven
means of identifying emergent properties
they stand as hypotheses for the sorts
of things that might observationally
stand out to us but maybe they won't and
part of the reason i'm interested in
this is that i don't want to make that
assumption and think and i want to be
open to the possibility that there'll be
weakly emergent things that do not leap
out to us
there may also be the converse there may
be things that that leap out to us
um
that are not in any interesting sense
emergent they may be you know what we
call before is nominally emergent just
they're just properties that inhere to a
hole that cannot adhere to the parts but
not in any particularly
interesting interesting sense well one
of the reasons why i asked is because i
mean number one i had been wondering
about that question independently but
number two
when it comes to consciousness one of
the facts features i should say of
consciousness that you yourself have
emphasized is
how the brain constructs a picture of
the world based on highly limited data
right
uh how we you know we don't just look at
the world in terms of pixels and then
build something up in a systematic way
we come with kind of templates of some
sort maybe i should let you say these in
your own words because you know what
you're talking about but but explain a
little bit about how that works
indeed that's that's actually the line
of work that i've been mainly following
for the last few years as well and it to
some extent it's gone along
relatively independently of our work on
emergence and so one of the interesting
prospects is how these things will
interact just as you're raising with
your question and i i don't know yet is
the the answer to that question
but they may
the
the idea of how the brain
uh forms its perceptions based on sparse
sensory data that's for me that's
grounded in a different way of thinking
about
what brains do
which is in terms of brains being
prediction machines
of one sort or another this is again an
extremely old idea that goes back in
philosophy you can trace it back to
plato to kant to um wherever you want to
stop on the way that um
we don't perceive we don't have direct
access to
reality as it is everything we see is
some sort of some sort of interpretation
of something that is ultimately
unknowable
yeah and
in psychology
there's this tradition going back to
people like the german polymath hermann
von helmholtz thinking about the brain
as an inference engine and perception as
the
result of a process of unconscious
inference
and the idea here is is really quite
quite straightforward it's that
sensory signals that bombard our sensory
surfaces the light waves that hit our
retinas the pressure waves that hit our
hair cells and our ears they don't come
with labels on saying what they're from
they don't come with labels saying which
part of the body they're hitting they
just trigger electrical signals which
flow into the brain and in the brain
it's dark it's quiet there's no sound
there's no light
the brain has to make sense
of these noisy and ambiguous
sensory signals
and the idea
about how it does this is that it's
doing some kind of bayesian inference on
the causes of these sensory signals the
brain is always trying to figure out
what are the most likely causes of the
continual barrage of sensory signals
that it swims in
and the content of our perceptual
experience at any one time
is the brain's
best guess it's the result of this
process of inference it's the posterior
uh it's combining sensory data with some
prior expectation or belief about the
way the world is and these prior beliefs
can come from evolution from development
or from your experience a few minutes
ago
all of these
prior expectations
uh provide context for interpreting
ambiguous sensory signals
and it's the interpretation that that is
what we perceive i think that's the
stronger claim that what we perceive is
not some readout of sensory signals that
that we just extract
features of increasing complexity as the
sensory signals stream into the brain
but the sensory signals are really there
just to
update and calibrate our top-down
perceptual predictions
and though and it's the collective
content of these top-down perceptual
predictions
that is what we perceive
there's another slight this is just
another slight extension for this which
i think is thought to say for it the
whole thing to make sense which is it's
one thing to say that the brain is
doing some basic inference on the causes
of sensory signals that it's somehow
doing this inference how is it doing it
again there could be many ways in which
brains could accomplish something like
this
one of the most popular proposals is
that it's engaged in predictive
processing or sometimes called
prediction error minimization
and this is the idea that the brain is
always has some kind of best guess about
the causes of its sensoria
and that it's continually updating that
by using sensory signals as prediction
errors
so this the stuff that's flowing into
the brain from the outside world
is really just the error the difference
between what the brain expects and what
it gets at every level of processing
within the brain this is kind of
counter-intuitive we're used to thinking
in terms of perception as reading out
the sensory signals
but i've come to think of it now as
no the sensory signals just
calibrate and what we actually perceive
is the stuff going in the other
direction the top-down predictions
um that are being reigned in by the
sensory prediction errors from the world
and that process
approximates bayesian inference if you
have a system that's
that's that's implementing this
prediction error minimization
then with some other assumptions you'll
find
that it does actually approximate
bayesian inference so this is the way or
this is at least one proposal about how
the so-called bayesian brain
works
so let me dig into that a little bit
because uh on the one hand i love it on
the other hand i don't really understand
it so uh the idea that you know we have
this
you know the brain
makes a prediction for what it's going
to see and and i can see that you know
an mpeg file right an encoded uh video
file on the internet like they saved a
lot of storage capacity by figuring out
that all you have to update is how the
image changes not including what the
image is at every moment right so the
brain is doing something like that but
clearly there are moments when you know
i look at something completely new when
a movie starts and i see something and
there has to be that first flash of
recognition does the brain sort of
shuffle through a bunch of possibilities
or do we know even know what's happening
in those moments
maybe it's yes there's there's some
interesting challenges so there's
there's challenges about how can you see
something new for the first time if you
live in a world of the already expected
yeah
but i think there are ways to address
these challenges and
the first way is that perception in this
view is something that's in that's very
deeply hierarchical
that our high level
uh perceptions about what's going on i
see a movie star or i i see whatever
happened the [ __ ] um out in the sea on
the beach here
um those high-level perceptual contents
are built up out of much lower level
things and classic vision science tells
us that parts of our visual system deal
with detecting variations in brightness
and then bit deeper in
get lines and then line segments and
shapes and all the way up to faces and
people and objects and places
uh
and so even if you see something that
you haven't
seen
before like
and it may be
a movie star that you weren't expecting
to see still going to share a lot of the
same lower level features with other
things that your perceptual system is
very used to making best guesses about
and so you will
so you you still do live in a world of
the mostly already expected and it's
only at this to the last bit that you
have to make a little a little leap and
see something new and sometimes that
might be even accompanied by this
psychological recognition that i'm
seeing something new some sort of
surprise thing
too so
it i think it i think it it does work
and
the brain also learns you know we so one
of the other
components of this way of thinking is
that
the brain encodes something that we'd
want to call a generative model so it
encodes
a model of the causes of sensory signals
this is how this is what supplies the
predictions that then get compared
against prediction errors
so for in a sense everything that we
perceive
is is constrained or everything that we
can perceive is constrained by
the generative models that are encoded
in our brains but these generative
models can change and develop over time
and um
we learn we can therefore learn to
perceive new things through experience
and i think we're all familiar with this
in some in some ways when you start
drinking red wine they all taste the
same but then after a while you learn to
make discriminations
and you have perceptually different
experiences your generative model
has developed to be able to
make distinct predictions for distinct
kinds of sensory signals whereas
previously it wasn't
it reminds me of of
stuff i read a while ago when i was
thinking when i was writing my first
trade book about the arrow of time
about how memory
works in the brain versus imagination
and prediction working in the brain and
fmri studies saying that uh
they used very very similar parts of the
brain maybe the same parts of the brain
in some sense which led to a hypothesis
which i'm not sure if it's
continued to be popular or not that
what we stored in our memories was not
uh a videotape of sets of images that we
saw but more like a screenplay and like
there's a little uh puppet theater in
the brain that we could sort of feed in
the script and it would put on a show
every time we wanted to remember
something so like we had some shapes
some sounds some pre-existing concepts
we could put into play and then the data
we needed to bring those to life was
much more compressed than if we
literally just had a whole bunch of
images
yeah i think there's something right
about that there's certainly something
very wrong about the idea of memory
being a video tape
or in general being some sort of
neurally implemented file storage system
that i think is an example of taking the
computer metaphor of the brain too far
computers are useful metaphors up to a
point but i think over extended they can
be radically misleading memory
definitely doesn't work like that in the
brain and there's so many empirical
examples of that not least that we tend
to have pretty bad memories and um and
the more often you remember something
the less accurate that memory becomes
every every act of remembering is a sort
of active regeneration as you put it
it's people in the screenplay reenacting
the the scene or something like that
so that every time you do it you change
it a bit
this has been a notorious problem in
things like eyewitness testimony that
that people's memories become
progressively less reliable
but often it they develop the conviction
that their memory is becoming more
reliable when in fact the opposite is
going on but i think there's a lot of
overlap between these ideas of of
perception
imagination
memory
dreaming even all the all these
categories that might seem to be
separate
leverage and utilize and refine
a highly overlapping set of underlying
mechanisms
so there's one one idea that i really
love in this area it's been around for a
while but it was very beautifully
articulated recently by eric hull
which is this idea of dreams
as
refining the generative models in the
brain
but if you can imagine doing it during
walking around doing your during your
everyday life
you're perceiving lots of things um
your brain is trying to fit all this
this sensory data that's coming in
but as with any statistical model
you can overfit if you if you try and
fit too many data points um you won't be
able to generalize very well to new
things this is just very basic stuff in
statistics right that yeah
you you just fit all the data points
then you have a new situation and you
find out you've not captured the
invariances that really matter um and so
you want to
guard against overfitting and so one
idea uh that that eric talks about
is that dreaming is a way of the brain
pushing back against this daily
overfitting during perception it's sort
of freewheeling its generative model
pruning all the unnecessary connections
um getting back down to the to the
basics so that you can see better the
next day okay it's still an idea it's
very little evidence for it but but it
to me it's it's a lovely way of thinking
about
what dreams are they're not just replays
of what happened in the day it's also
not true they're fundamentally
meaningless either they may play an
interesting
semi-computational role in tuning our
perceptual systems
well there's a at least a very cheap and
obvious connection between this
discussion and the emergence discussion
based simply on the fact that coarse
graining is really really important
right uh data compressibility is really
really important and i think that
you know from a physicist's point of
view normally i like to play the role of
the physicist adding insight here but i
think that physicists are caught a
little bit in this dream of being
laplace's demon right like if we had
perfect information what would we be
able to predict about the future etc
whereas almost all of our experience and
understanding of reality comes on the
basis of very very tiny amounts of data
compared to the whole thing that is out
there and in in both this idea of uh
that the brain is a inference engine and
predictive processing and so forth and
the idea of emergence and higher level
descriptions we're
thinking or discovering ways to say
sensible useful things about the world
by saying a very very tiny fraction of
everything there is to be said
yeah i think that's right i think
there is a connection there quite how
much use you can make of that connection
is something i don't have a good
intuition about but certainly this idea
of of course graining
runs both through predictive processing
where you where you indeed you extract
relatively abstract high-level models of
the causes of sensory data which allow
you to generalize and the general case
of weak emergence that that we were
talking about that's true what we do
with it i don't know what we do with it
yeah well you know this we need to leave
open problems for the listeners to solve
this is part of our job here on the
podcast but okay uh sort of winding up i
do want to just let you i'm not even
sure if i have a specific question here
but there's another really big idea that
you emphasize in the new book that you
have out and elsewhere that is very
relevant to consciousness which is the
role of the body as well as the brain in
this whole thing and it's something i've
alluded to on other episodes of the
podcast but i'd like to hear your take
on it the idea you know again if if
physicists sometimes fall into this
dream of being laplace's demon then uh
other people who are more computer-y uh
in in orientation fall into the idea of
the brain as an information processing
machine and it could be on a computer on
a hard drive just as well as it could be
in a human brain but there is something
in de facto about the fact that our
brains are embedded in bodies and we
keep getting this input both internally
and externally that really plays a role
in what we call consciousness yeah
yes the question is what role and how
fundamental that is and there's a lot of
things
to talk about here and
the possibly the most
important one or certainly the one that
comes up very frequently
is this idea of substrate independence
so um
there's a very
common assumption or position in
thinking about consciousness
that it doesn't matter
that the brain happens to be made out of
neurons that happen to be made out of
carbon based stuff and so on
that if you wired a computer up in the
right way programmed it in the right way
that it would be conscious too
this argument
find myself just very agnostic about
i i just don't think there are good
knock-down reasons to believe either
that consciousness is substrate
independent
or that it isn't if you take one
position and say that
consciousness is a thing that only
particular kinds of
substrates physical systems can have
things made out of neurons let's say or
carbon then of course you've got to give
an explanation of why that is
and i don't have an explanation of why
that or a good explanation of why that
must
be there are some intuitions why i think
it's
it's not a silly idea but there's
certainly no
knock-down argument
but the same applies the other way
around too
if it is substrate independent then i
want to know what's a good positive
reason for believing that because not
everything
is substrate independent the usual
example is if i simulate
a weather system on a computer
it's a simulation it doesn't get wet and
windy inside the computer
rain is not substrate independent
um
and so what's consciousness like is it
more like
is it more like something like playing
go which which is substrate independent
i can get a computer do that to actually
play and go as we have we've seen
recently with deepmind
or is it something more like the weather
which which is not
um
all conscious systems we know of so far
are housed in brains majors made of
neurons that are embedded within bodies
that are embodied in environments and so
on so it's a good default starting point
to at
least wonder whether consciousness is
something
that
requires
a biological system or to put it more
weakly
in order to understand consciousness we
have to understand
it's substrate a bit more deeply and i
think
this is useful because doing so
pushes back against another
unfortunate tendency of the of
taking the computer metaphor a bit too
far which is this sharp distinction
between hardware and software
that the software is the mind and the
hardware is the is the brain
there's no such sharp distinction
in real biological systems yes there are
activity patterns and yes there's the
neurons are wired up in particular ways
but there's chemicals washing about
every time neurons fire the structure
changes a bit as well
and then how far do you go down even
single neurons have very very
complicated activity patterns relating
what their inputs to their outputs
so there's no clean separation of
hardware from software or wetware from
mindware and if there's no clean
separation
then at what point do you even make the
claim that something is substrate
independent where does the substrate
start
so that's one reason i i
i feel uneasy with this idea of
of consciousness being substrate
independence
and and that brings us to the question
what else does thinking about
the biological instantiation of
consciousness bring to the table and i
actually think it brings an awful lot we
talked about
this idea of the brain being a
prediction machine inferring the causes
of sensory signals
we tend to think of
brains as
as in the business of perceiving the
outside world and acting on the outside
world and the body at most as maybe
something that enables this and takes
the brain from meeting to meeting and um
but is otherwise unimportant just has to
be kept going
but
bodies
are
the the purpose of having a brain in the
first place
is to keep the body alive that's the
fundamental evolutionary duty of the
brain is to keep the the body alive
and the brain is in the business of
sensing and perceiving its internal
state as well from the perspective of
the brain the internal state of the body
is also
inaccessible and remote and has to be
inferred it gets sensory data about
let's say the heart rate and blood
pressure levels and all this stuff
but they're still comprised electrical
signals it has to make inferences about
the state of the body but the inferences
in this case are much more geared
towards controlling the system rather
than figuring out what things are or
where they are
my brain doesn't care where in the body
my liver is but it does care that it's
doing the job that it should do
so when i perceive the internal state of
my body i don't perceive my internal
organs
as having shapes or colors or locations
but i certainly do perceive
how well my body is doing at staying
alive whether i'm hungry or thirsty or
in pain or suffering or
so the character of the perceptual
experience is really determined by the
role
the predictions are playing but it's
still predictions
so i think we can understand a great
deal about the nature
the content of our conscious experiences
of the self these emotions and moods and
the simple experience of just being a
living organism
that i think grounds all of our
experiences
everything the larger claim would be
that everything that we experience even
our experiences of the outside world
ultimately grounded in
the predictive mechanisms
that evolved and develop and operate
from moment to moment in service of
regulating our bodily physiology that's
a very deep connection between
consciousness and life that is not the
same as saying that you have to be alive
to be conscious or that everything that
is alive is conscious but it's saying
that that's that's the way to understand
uh how our conscious experiences are
formed and shaped
so since we're past the hour mark on the
podcast we can be a little bit more
speculative and uh
and not be as beholden to rigor as we
were in the beginning parts so uh let me
let me just
you said i think two things that i want
to have different levels of signing on
to uh the part about how in fact our
consciousness is enormously influenced
by the fact that we live in a body and
the body lives in a world and we're
getting inputs from inside and outside
i'm a hundred percent on on that and i
think that uh in fact i once proposed
this as a solution to the fermi paradox
why aren't there any aliens uh because
we all because you know the idea would
be that if you get sufficiently
technologically advanced everyone
uploads their brains into the computer
and then when they are removed from the
uh demands of living in environment
right of eating and sleeping and all
those things we decide that you know
there's just no point in living anymore
we don't do anything that we don't ever
leave the planet it's become sort of a
meaningless nirvana uh and we don't
explore the galaxy um but
this begs the question of whether or not
uploading is a thing that could
happen and
you know you raise this other issue of
the substrate independence which
i'm less on board with a little bit uh
there are people we had nick bostrom on
the podcast who thinks we could be in a
simulation maybe rain is substrate
independent if you simulate rain
accurately enough it's just as good
david chalmers of all people
makes the argument that things that
happen in a simulation are just as real
as things that happened in the real
world so do you see a distinction
between those two parts of the argument
or do they sort of group together in
your
mind i i'm a bit suspicious of this the
simulation argument of nick bostrom so
for me the logic runs a bit the other
way around that
this the possibility of us living within
a simulation requires substrate
independence to be true yeah
that's
that's just that's what and that's
that's one of the assumptions that
in nick's presentations of the argument
he does sort of skate over a bit and say
well this is this is a relatively common
that's fine and we just have to worry
about the other things about the the
likelihood of civilization getting to
the stage where we have all these
descendants who are for some reason
interested in building ancestor
simulations and so on but before even
getting there i just
don't think it's a safe assumption
that substrate independence
is true
if it were to be true then indeed it
might be harder to really
know whether we are in some sort of base
reality or or in some simulation but
i think in terms of assigning prior
credences to these sorts of things i
think it's much more likely that we
that substrate actually this is this
could be construed as a good argument
for why consciousness
must be substrate dependent because if
consciousness is substrate independent
then maybe the simulation argument holds
up and we're living in a simulation and
i don't want to reach that conclusion
therefore consciousness must be
substrate dependent not a very good
argument
out there maybe some people um ready
that will like it
yeah well you know i always uh um
encourage the listeners to be good
bayesians one way or the other and i
think you've lived up to that uh goal
just bringing up our prior accredences
right there so setting a good example
for everyone out there thinking about
emergence and consciousness anil seth
thanks so much for being on the
mindscape podcast
thank you sean it's a real pleasure and
a privilege thank you
[Music]
you